[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à peine d'être élu que déjà elle donnait
le temps à la relation qu'elle soit
imposée à Ottawa son avertissement est
sans équivoque pas question d'accepter
les cibles de carbone neutralité infligé
a-t-elle insisté par Ottawa sur les
secteurs pétroliers de réseau électrique
de sa province à quoi doit-on s'attendre
du règne de la première ministre
albertaine j'en discute avec Sarah big
stratège conservatrice que je retrouve à
Calgary merci d'être avec nous madame
bixb merci merci de recevoir pour ma
tête
Daniel Smith et on l'a entendu en
revenant de la pause tout à l'heure a
dit bienvenue à un autre miracle des
prairies comme si comme si sa victoire
était loin d'être certaine c'est comme
ça qu'on doit l'interpréter donc la
victoire
de lundi soir a été décidé par quelques
milliers de votes environ 2320 tu serais
on fait la différence entre un
gouvernement conservateur et un
gouvernement journée au démocrate
présentement il y a deux côtés qui sont
en rencontre judiciaire aujourd'hui mais
c'était vraiment une joute de terrain
c'était vraiment une bataille de terrain
c'est la sortie de vote qui a fait une
différence c'est la sortie de votre qui
a fait une différence on dit toujours en
anglais que
Carl grise de barreau ground Calgary
était le champ de bataille pour cette
élection et puis à ce moment-là c'était
de savoir qui était capable d'aller
chercher le plus de Voda et de rejoindre
le plus de Voltaire de sortir le vote ça
fait quand même quelques décennies qu'il
y a pas eu une opposition aussi
substantielle devant le gouvernement
comment est-ce qu'on peut envisager de
voir ces deux parties-là travailler en
équipe compte tenu des positions qui
sont très éloignées entre madame nothing
madame Smith très différente bon tout le
monde va avoir à mettre de l'eau un peu
d'eau dans leur vin et puis c'est sûr
qu'il va avoir des batailles c'est sûr
qu'il va avoir des débats assez
échauffés mais comme je disais la
semaine dernière
des personnes qui va être élue lundi ne
doit pas oublier que 50% de la
population albertaine ne va pas voter
pour elle donc à ce moment-là il va
falloir essayer de se rediriger vers le
centre et puis vraiment essayer de
diriger la province en ayant l'intérêt
de tous les Albertins
en tête donc c'est pas une victoire à 77
qu'on voit ici
campagne avec une approche conservatrice
très à droite
on a beaucoup parlé du mouvement TAKE
BACK Albert entre autres
quel est son défi parce que là elle se
retrouve à la tête d'un gouvernement qui
n'est pas représenté dans les grandes
villes ou à peu près qui est absent
d'adminton qui est absent Calgary
comment on gère ça quand on forme un
gouvernement donc à ce moment-là les
recommandations si j'étais à la table ce
serait d'essayer de garder un cabinet
d'environ 12 à 13 ministres donc garder
les ministres qui sont du côté
progressifs qui sont plus au centre
droit qu'à l'extrême droite ça ça va
être la clé pour être capable de garder
une voix qui est plus prorative plus
centré et qui parlent plus à la
population générale en Alsace
un peu plus à droite monsieur monsieur
Kenny a fini par en payer le prix quand
il sait qu'il s'en sert trouver un peu
plus au centre lui ça va être une
balance qui va être extrêmement
difficile et puis de la manière
ça va être vraiment intéressant d'avoir
comment elle va réussir à balancer son
acte qu'on le veuille ou non il va faire
quelle écoute des deux côtés mais ça va
être dans j'espère vraiment que Madame
Smith va être capable de rester au
centre droit
plutôt qu'à l'extrême droite
qui peut durer le mandat complet ou
est-ce qu'il y a des risques de voir
Madame Speed se retrouver dans une
situation où et pour tomber ou elle
pourrait perdre des membres de son focus
ou après se retrouver enfin juste
situation ça c'est la question 100
dollars en ce moment on va voir dans les
prochains mois on va voir les politiques
elles vont implémenter on va voir de
quelle manière elle va former son
cabinet et puis à ce moment-là
idéalement c'est qu'elle reste quatre
ans mais à tékback alberra apporte quand
même beaucoup d'instabilité au niveau du
parti donc on va voir de quelle manière
si l'extrême droite ou si les modérés
vont être capable de reprendre le dessus
et le fédéral madame on en parlait en
présentation madame Smith a envoyé quand
même un message assez clair à Ottawa en
disant vos politiques environnementales
ça fonctionne pas ici puis on va s'y
opposer à quel genre de relation peut
s'attendre donc Madame Smith a également
mentionné que vous voulez faire un
report à zéro avec les relations avec le
gouvernement fédéral
quel genre de comment je pourrais dire
que les gens d'entente est-ce qu'on va
réussir à négocier avec le gouvernement
fédéral des deux côtés ça va être il va
il va avoir un emprunte il va falloir
aussi en laisser pour faire sûr que en
bout de ligne
les albertin sont aussi canadiens et
puis on doit faire sur que le marché du
travail ne s'écroule pas de faire sûr
que l'industrie pétrolière ne s'écroule
pas que se déplace vers un objectif de
notre zéro qu'on travaille sur les
captures de méthane sur les captures de
carbone et puis qu'on vienne à des
décisions très créatives et innovative
ce qu'on peut se amener à la table et
réussir à atteindre notre objectif qui
va être raisonnable pour les deux ça
avait exactement
bonne journée bonne journée